I'm curious uh what do you think fans
will be saying when episode 8 ends oh
man
um I I hope that it's it's just a
feeling of you know that things have
culminated in a great way
um I I but who knows I mean I I just I'm
just excited for it to be out there I
feel like we're building towards
something that's really
um that's really been earned over three
seasons and so
um I'm just looking forward to whatever
that reaction is very diplomatic answer
so I might have heard that the
Mandalorian season four starts filming
uh this year and I'm just curious if you
want to comment on that
I don't think it's a secret that the day
that John has uh is is excited about
continuing to tell stories he's written
season four and I I don't know I'd be
shocked if that if they just stopped me
this point but yeah I mean I think just
the way that I think that the shows come
together in the process around the shows
um I know that they're deep into to
starting the the prep and and the
pre-production process on the show now
exactly when it goes to lens and things
start to to shoot I don't I don't know
but I but I know is that you being
covert or you really don't know no no no
I really I really don't know you know um
because it's a it's a home machine how
these things come together and obviously
there are a lot of shows uh that are
that are also being created at the same
time and so the exact date of production
I I don't know but I know that it's
obviously in the works and and things
are are coming together and in its usual
way in terms of the team coming together
at this point so yeah my last thing for
you um so obviously thrawn and other
characters that have never been depicted
in live action are coming what what do
you want to tease people about thrawn
because obviously look you've seen
footage whether it be Ahsoka whether it
be showing up in episode 8 I don't know
but what do you I don't know have you
seen so if you've seen thrawn anywhere
how did
I think I think I think I think you
might have seen footage uh behind the
scenes of Ahsoka or you know what I mean
what do you want I mean you know
I've not seen them yet
[Music]
there's some people adding them there's
some people here who might have saw some
things but you know I don't know
look I'm not gonna be the one right I'm
not gonna be the one Dave's having a
great day
he's gonna be here he's gonna be
somewhere soon put that put that on him
but um now Abby look I think Dave has
created obviously a world of characters
uh that that started with the animated
series and and have made their way into
the show uh starting with the Soca and
so it would not be a great surprise
obviously
um if this was all building towards
another great reveal like that and so I
think uh
um you know so Dave Dave's vision is is
obviously has its imprint on on
Mandalorian and clearly as Ahsoka starts
to come together and we learn more we
will uh you know we will see more about
what his plans are